hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for anime opera and since dragon
maid is such a cultured and
sophisticated anime i decided to take on
a sophisticated english accent for this
video okay not really it's forward for
anabe here hi and today i will be
explaining all the main series dragons
from miss kobayashi's dragon maid now
just like my boy axel i am also a part
of team opera as one of their editors
and after a little banter at my expense
for liking dragon maid a little too much
the the lads asked me to make a video on
it so goes without saying not only as
part of the team but also a long time
fan of the channel let's just say i'm a
little psyched for this now i will be
putting some bite size information
together on each of the main dragons
looking into who they are why they came
to the human world a bit on their
backstories their powers etc it's gonna
be amazing now one of my most favorite
things about this series and why i
personally think it resonates with so
many different people is its vast
collection of very colorful characters
each with their own unique personalities
that blend together very well with one
another everyone seems to have a
favorite you know so let us know who
yours is in the comment section below
and if you stick around till the very
end of this video i'll let you know who
mine is now if you do enjoy this dragon
made video you know what to do channel
the dragon within and obliterate that
like button if you haven't already make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also follow
anime uproar on twitter and instagram at
animeopro and if you really want to feel
free to follow me as well at 414 anime
underscore thank you of course this
video will contain dragon maid manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned okay let's kick
this video off with our main girl toru
toru is a very outgoing dragon with a
happy and caring nature toru is
incredibly cheerful and kind to every
human that she meets now tori's kind and
caring nature can take a complete 180
when she feels people are a threat to
kobayashi well a threat to toru in a
potential love interest to kobayashi
anyway so toru is the main dragon of the
series and a part of the chaos faction
the dragons in the series are each split
into one of three different factions
there is the chaos faction who look to
destroy humans as well as their
civilizations and even their gods then
there's the harmony faction whose goal
is to make the world a place where the
humans and dragons can live peacefully
side by side and then finally there is
the spectating faction who as the name
suggests are on neither side and choose
not to get involved with said matters
our girl toru is the daughter of
democles the emperor of demise and was
brought up to hate all humans she was
taught that all humans were evil
inferior and above all foolish creatures
now one fateful day toru was wounded in
battle by a god leading a human army
against her and on the verge of death
toru was forced to retreat to the human
world it was here that toru met a drunk
human woman who changed her entire
perception on the humans as she not only
helped to remove the holy sword from
toru's body but the woman also accepted
her even in her dragon form the two
forged a close bond that night and with
nowhere to call home in the human world
the human kobayashi offered the dragon a
place to stay taking kobayashi up on her
offer and after learning that she had a
very strong love for maids toru paid her
a visit at her apartment to begin her
life as kobayashi's maid now on her
flight to kobayashi's apartment toru
flew over a maid cafe called maid cafe
cosy and decided to transform her scales
in human form to match the same attire
these maids were wearing not knowing
that this was more cosplay than the
traditional maid attire kobayashi often
likes to point out her faults with it so
in her human form toru looks to be of
average height she is described as
having a full figure with large breasts
and thick thighs now the oppai as we
know from toru herself are a d-cup
because d is for dragon it's still one
of my most favorite moments in the
series now in dragon form toru is your
more traditional dragon let's say she is
a huge green european dragon with a
lighter green belly black wings and
piercing yellow eyes in terms of power
toru is one of the more powerful dragons
in the series toru controls the element
of fire with expertise and has mastered
it so that it can be used in many
different ways as such her flames come
in a variety of sizes she has a large
powerful blast of fire an incinerating
beam and can also produce small bursts
of fire that can still cause a fair
amount of destruction
now as a dragon she is of course capable
of fly as well as possessing sharp teeth
and claws not only this but she has
insane strength and super speed and it's
not all physical strength and power as
she also possesses some psychic-like
abilities such as clairvoyance using
this ability toru can see through
objects she also has perception blocking
which allows her to become invisible to
others on top of that toru also has a
super rare skill called portal opening
using this toru can open portals to
other worlds and dimensions now the
fateful encounter with kobayashi the
night that they met caused toru to fall
deeply in love with her and let's just
say that our dragon girl is certainly
not afraid of showing her that toru has
made many advances on kobayashi both
verbally and through her actions with
the most entertaining of the bunch being
toru trying to find a way to get
kobayashi to eat her tail meat now i
absolutely love the relationship built
between these two it balances out the
show's light-hearted humor with some
pretty deep emotional connection between
two people or as a person in a dragon in
this case but whatever it's it's a story
of connection and how introducing a new
person into your life can completely
change it this story just warms my heart
you know and i'll always be rooting for
these too next up is none other than the
kawaii lolly dragon kana kana is quiet
and soft-spoken and she often conveys
her own emotions through very small yet
very cute expressions one of my most
favorite karda traits is her curious and
observant nature the best way this is
visually represented is how we see
khana's habit of eating bugs and small
animals is
cute now despite kana's age over the
humans which she is said to be around 7
000 years old she definitely has
child-like characteristics such as you
know she gets bored of routines easily
she loves to play and of course likes
pulling pranks and getting into mischief
kana is the youngest of the dragons and
came to the human world because she was
exiled from the dragon world due to the
previously mentioned mischief poor karna
was simply trying to get the attention
of her parents by playing some pranks
but ultimately as punishment for said
pranks in the dragon world she ended up
being temporarily exiled to the human
world so she could reflect on her
actions poor porkana now being a young
dragon kana is the only dragon in the
main cast that is not a part of the
three dragon factions conor's human form
has the appearance of a young girl and
when she joins school she is in the
third grade she is described as very
cute and while i totally agree with this
there must be no looting of the lolly
dragon i'm watching you comment section
now as for her dragon form we don't know
exactly what type of dragon she is but
karna is a white feathered dragon with
blue eyes a blue eyes white lolly dragon
if you will moving on to powers kana's
element is that of lightning she
generates thunder that she can then
manipulate into some pretty powerful
attacks of course the most noticeable
attack was in her spa with toru where
she unleashed that lethal lolly dragon
kamehameha kana again is the youngest of
the dragons meaning she is unfortunately
the weakest of them too as she can't
perform some of the skills such as
perception blocking that the grown-up
dragons can another example unlike in
the dragon world the nature of the human
world makes it hard for younger dragons
such as kana to draw upon its natural
manner so she has to absorb it from her
surroundings instead the visual
reference for this was when we saw her
plugging her tail into the power socket
in kobayashi's apartment moving on to
the fan service of the series lukewarm
like legit lucoa was actually designed
as the main fan service in mind for the
series lucoa has a very carefree
laid-back nature she is full of wisdom
with the other characters often seeking
out advice from her what she lacks
however seems to be modesty she is
extremely flirtatious and certainly not
afraid to wear the most skimpy of
outfits her personality is best
referenced in her interactions with
showter she teases him and puts him in
the most awkward situations a boy his
age could be in so much so that shota
actually sees her as more of a demon or
a succubus than that of a dragon in her
human form lukawa has a noise hourglass
figure with very largo pie oppai aside
her most standout feature for me is her
eyes she has heterochromia which is a
difference in color between the iris in
both eyes and as a visual reference i
may as well add my own best girl kuromi
tokusaki into the video i mean i could
have easily added shoto todoroki as a
visual reference as i know a lot of you
love the uproar my hero academia content
here but i'm a proud degenerate and for
the minority of you that know me you'll
understand anyway as for her dragon form
lukawa refers to herself as a feathered
serpent she is also one of the largest
dragons moving on to powers and
abilities luka is actually the strongest
dragon in the show not only that but she
is also a former deity so i said a
former deity a former goddess now the
interesting thing about luka's backstory
is that she is actually based on aztec
mythology luka's name is quetzalcoatl
the god that she is based on shares the
same name now as the tale goes she was
given cursed liquor by one of her
friends luka became drunk after
consuming it and was then involved in an
affair with her sister described only as
scandalous because of this incident luka
was then stripped of her title and
exiled though even without her deity
powers luka is still incredibly powerful
so powerful in fact that her powers are
said to be far beyond torus and even
that of fafnirs despite having all of
this power luka actually hates conflict
and will turn her back on battle even if
it means leaving people in need of help
behind knowing this it is no surprise
that luqua is a part of the spectating
faction
next up we are moving on to toru's old
travel buddy and now rival elma elma
came to the human world with one goal in
mind to bring the dragons back
particularly she wants to bring back
toru even if that meant dragging her
back by force however despite elmer's
very stubborn and persistent nature this
didn't go to plan and you know a part of
this is down to her very obvious
weakness
food her love for food is actually
borderline addiction as elmer has often
run out of money because she just can't
help herself due to another weakness of
hers which is indecisiveness so this
gluttony of hers is without question her
greatest downfall as our girl elmer can
be so easily swayed into doing anything
when presented with food as a prize now
in her human form elmer has again a very
noise figure and i know she is very
popular with the fanbase but not only
that it was stated in one of the
spin-off manga series following elmer's
daily life entitled miss kobayashi's
dragon maid elmer's office lady diary
the elma is incredibly desirable enough
so that it's said she is that attractive
that she can make other women doubt
their own sexuality and i don't know how
that feels personally but i i bet it's
nice elma fits into the human world
nicely as she works at the same company
as kobayashi and a fun fact for you but
elma is the only main dragon in the
series that lives on her own whereas the
other dragons live with a human as for
her dragon form elmar is a blue sea
serpent she is a very long water dragon
with a brown horn on her forehead and
the trident that she carries around in
her human form is her tail in her dragon
form elmar is a very powerful dragon who
is on par with toru being a water dragon
her power is based on that water element
and this means that elma is very mobile
when in water elmer is also a part of
the harmony faction like i mentioned
earlier in the video it is her job to
protect the humans so they can live in
peace with the dragons now being part of
the harmony faction elmer has a lot of
support magic behind her as seen when
she erected a huge barrier to protect
the city in toru's fight against lulu
one of the things i love about elma is
her relationship with toru in the past
though the two were from different
factions they put that aside to travel
the human world together however the
truth didn't last for long as toru found
out that the humans started to worship
elmar as a goddess in toru's eyes elma
was taking advantage of her position and
she retaliated by completely destroying
a palace that the humans had built for
alma this led to a huge devastating
fight between the two dragons which
ultimately resulted in elma retreating
the two became rivals after this and we
have seen some hilarious exchanges
between them since then moving on to an
absolute legend and one that on many
occasions i have referred to as the true
mvp of dragon maid that is none other
than fafnir fafnir is almost your most
stereotypical dragon in the sense that
his life prior to coming the human world
was spent in a cave protecting his
treasure from the humans though what is
interesting about him is that it is
suggested that he was actually once
fully human and later gained the ability
to transform into a dragon fafnir
another chaos faction dragon is a
solitary figure that is shrouded in
mystery and upon coming to the human
world he definitely didn't shy away from
showcasing his hatred for the humans it
wasn't until he met takia who introduced
him to video games and the otaku culture
which our boy fafnir became extremely
addicted to by the way that he learned
to tolerate humans well
to a certain extent for him anyway
fafnir does have a somewhat calm and
collected demeanor about him but for me
i think his character is extremely
relatable he is able to convey a mood to
display his emotions all without
speaking this chat just always seems to
be unimpressed by everything and
everyone around him so in his human form
fafnir is described as a handsome young
man he definitely has a somewhat
sebastian michaelis vibe about him in
his butler suit as for his dragon form
fafnir is a huge black dragon standing
at 20 meters tall he's also pretty scary
as he has multiple pairs of deep red
eyes fafnir also has another form not
only that but he is the only dragon in
the series to have more than one form
this or the form of his is a humanoid
one this thing is monstrous in
appearance with a huge muscular build
purple skin two horns the same deep red
eyes and his mouth has many big sharp
fangs
power wise fafnir is one of the most
powerful dragons in the series toru a
pretty powerful chaos faction dragon
herself has said that she is yet to beat
him in a one-on-one fight in fact the
only other main dragon in the series
capable of beating him is lukewa and
like i said earlier fafnir is a dragon
shrouded in mystery and his powers are
no exception we do know that one of
fafnir's main powers is creating potent
curses the incantations for the curses
he makes are so powerful that when
written down even a human without magic
powers of their own can perform these
curses and he actually wrote a book with
all these curses in them and tried to
sell them at comiket luckily not a
single person bought a copy which you
know it did damage fafnir's pride but
it's it's probably a good thing finally
we have the newest dragon introduced to
the anime and one that came with a fair
bit of controversy the huge booba dragon
ilulu ilulu came to the human world to
battle toru alulu had found out that she
was coexisting in the human world with a
human and decided to target her but
ended up becoming kobayashi's third
dragon resident now i mentioned the word
controversy earlier and this is all down
to ilulu's human appearance in her human
form ilulu is short in high and looks
fairly young and i guess you could argue
that her main feature is her enormous
boobers i i know that caused quite a
stir where the anime only found out
about her but they serve a purpose they
serve a purpose and we'll touch on that
a bit later also interestingly elulu is
currently the only dragon in the main
cast who is yet to have her dragon form
revealed so ilulu has a sad backstory
and had been brainwashed by the other
dragons which led to her becoming a
chaos faction dragon herself illulu
actually grew up playing with humans and
was on very good terms with them one of
the human children actually made a doll
for her but ilulu's parents strongly
disliked her interacting with them and
destroyed the doll unfortunately it gets
worse as both of her parents were
eventually killed by humans now she felt
as if the humans hadn't done anything
wrong as it wasn't all humans who were
responsible but she did stop playing
with those human children the other
dragons around her then groomed a lulu
into hating the humans and planted the
idea in her mind that the humans and
dragons could not co-exist upon coming
to the human world ilulu's mind was
changed when she met and spoke to
kobayashi her early days in the series
follow her adjusting to the human world
and working out what she wants to do
with herself now she is here power wise
ilulu shares the same main fire element
as toru and going back to the booba and
how i said that they did serve a purpose
they do i promise ilulu has stated that
the reason that hers are so big is
because they are where she stores her
fire for her attacks ilulu is also
similar to kana in the fact that she
can't generate her own mana in the human
world and must absorb it from her
surroundings in lulu's case she
generates mana by eating fire and that
is it every main dragon from miss
kobayashi's dragon maid explained make
sure to let us know in the comment
section below who your favorite dragon
is as promised i shall reveal mine now
i'm a huge fan of fafnir's vibe and i
really enjoy carla's screen time but for
me toru has to be my favorite boring
answer i know but if i need to watch a
series to get those feel-good vibes i'll
always go to this show because toru just
makes me smile man she does now this
video was a lot of fun to make and it
was an absolute pleasure to meet you all
today huge thanks to the anime opera
lads annie mac and gozan for letting me
talk about this series on the channel
it's one of my favorites so i honestly
jumped at the chance so if you enjoyed
this video and you'd like to see me
cover other series like this on the
channel make sure to let the guys know
by smashing that like button if you
haven't already make this the video you
subscribe and hit the notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future anime or broad videos and of
course you can follow us on twitter and
instagram at animeobraw or at 414 anime
underscore and i want to give a big
thank you to all our anime or raw
patreons for making videos like this one
possible a special thank you to alpha
sigma the absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twego himself and of
course all of our the one-tier patreons
the ones who stand above all other clans
in grata pate heffer al-jazal dr cortman
the toasted chi the spike 8227 emperor
otaku spidey life tinel tungsten tarcus
baked buddhist cody heber and monkey d
quilly and of course i want to thank our
pro hero patrons including the one and
only gilgamesh the red-haired raven
angel cruz anatoly kazitsky very gucci
alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami and
water joanne garcia ted not ted fatboy
games corey mcgowan metal mama deadly
sane and soul rye slice and dice if you
enjoy our videos and feel they are
adding some value to your life please
consider supporting us on patreon even a
dollar gives you access to our exclusive
patreon discord and we'll get your name
featured in our videos alongside these
fantastic people thanks again for
watching we can't wait to see you in the
next one till next time
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you